way because when their full context came
out all of a sudden all that talk about
we got to cancel him and this is
terrible oh so but i i just want to say
this is
all of it right
the performance when we podcast and we
do live shows and stuff right it's it's
a show
word yeah it's just a show people take
it literally they pick it apart doesn't
that we're just trying to entertain
people and by the way and even on that
line on that in that vein i think
the problem with podcasts is you know
people think they know you because of
this yeah and you especially bobby
you're so vulnerable and open on these
things and then there's so much of it
that is like your performance and so
much of it is like it blends together so
these fans think they know what's going
on yeah you know they think they know so
then like anything we've had like when
we have like where people think it's a
beef yeah yeah you know there's no beef
there's no beef so all day on my damn
twitch yeah i i gotta get people every
day oh this is why bobby doesn't play
with you this is why bobby bob yeah it's
so bad i have to have a command
command bobby so my mods know so when
somebody asks about bobby command bobby
comes up and he goes he goes here's
where you could dm him
your moderator said i had my moderator
set it up because because what i'm just
trying to i'm just trying to put out
there to people it's like they don't
know and i tell people you're not privy
to our relationship all the time like
they weren't at with us for an hour
sitting at the taco place having a good
talk yeah they don't need to know
everything but the thing is they think
they know everything also because of
this tiny bits and pieces not the whole
picture not the whole picture but also
that version of us at because we talked
about it even yeah at the taco place
it's like
if they recorded that conversation and
put people would just rip it apart and
go [ __ ] this is so boring
right i know all right
it's the most boring thing it's
innocuous i fell asleep at lunch it was
just falling asleep because i listened
to each other
we're literally talking about like real
things about life and feeling and this
and that right and then we come up here
and everything's like a show we got a
like
it's a show it's not
[ __ ] ain't real bitching not real it
doesn't wear lingerie
this is a [ __ ] show oh it's a show
baby please please
it's a sh wait wait i'm sorry it's a
what
it's a show
[Laughter]
there's the thai new tiger belly meme
right there yeah this is honestly put it
on hip-hop though it's a sh sh
this whole thing that i'm doing now is a
good
comparison to
what you just said which is like this
[ __ ] is not real like
krusty kalila is real that's real like
that's real but we're gonna put on a
different version of ourselves and
exaggerate and embellish and honestly
it does get us in trouble once in a
while but i hope to god people have
common sense to know that it's like it's
just not you know what yeah you know
what though they i i agree with you we
want people to have common sense but
what i enjoy about this platform is it
don't i don't give a [ __ ] because you
know why we get to come back the next
episode and
say some more stuff about it and if we
need to talk about it again we can keep
doing it so the people that are like oh
i can't believe they said this we can
come back and go